Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello, welcome to the final episode in what has been our very first four-episode series, and it has been on Russia, the recent history of Russia, end of the Soviet Union, rise of Putin, obviously very, very immediate, important subject at the moment. And we have reached the stage where Putin has become president of Russia. So Dominic, the election of 2000, is Putin, I mean, is he a popular figure at this point? Is he well known? Or is he a kind of new broom? It's the funny thing. He's unknown. A year earlier, he was unknown. He's a new broom. A year earlier, he was completely unknown.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。大家好，欢迎收看我们首个四集系列的最后一集。本集的主题是俄罗斯、俄罗斯的近期历史、苏联解体以及普京的崛起。显然，这是当下非常、非常紧迫且重要的课题。我们已经迎来了普京成为俄罗斯总统的阶段。多米尼克，在 2000 年的大选中，普京——我的意思是，他在此时是一个受欢迎的人物吗？他当时很有名吗？还是说他算是一个政坛新面孔？说来有趣。他当时默默无闻。就在一年前，他还默默无闻。他是个新人。一年前，他完全是个无名之辈。
But by, what is it, April 2000, I think it is, he is identified with the Second Chechen War, which has been a great success from the Russian perspective because they've basically wiped the floor with the – Putin, I think his expression is he says, we've greased the terrorists, I think is his expression. He sort of has this populist way of talking about the war that pleases a lot of ordinary Russians. So just on the Chechen War, there is a guerrilla war that goes on for years. There's the Beslan siege. Remember that, Tom?
但在大约 2000 年 4 月时，他已经与第二次车臣战争联系在了一起。从俄罗斯的角度来看，这是一次巨大的成功，因为他们基本上把叛军——普京，我记得他的原话是，我们把恐怖分子给“干掉”了，大概是这个意思。他用这种民粹主义的方式谈论战争，迎合了许多普通俄罗斯人。说到车臣战争，那场游击战持续了多年。还有别斯兰人质事件。汤姆，你还记得吗？
In the school 2004 where Chechen militants took hundreds of people hostage in the theatre on both occasions, the Russian armed forces stormed the place where the people are being held hostage and lots of people are killed in the crossfire. Horrific. But Putin ends up winning in Chechnya. So the Chechen guy who they install in the long run is a guy called Ramzan Kadyrov. Are you familiar with him, Tom? No. He is an absolutely terrible man. Is he the one who's still on the scene now?
2004 年在那个学校里，车臣武装分子在剧院劫持了数百名人质。在这两起事件中，俄罗斯武装部队都对关押人质的地点进行了强攻，导致许多人在交火中丧生。太可怕了。但普京最终在车臣赢得了胜利。所以他们长期扶植的车臣领导人是一个叫拉姆赞·卡德罗夫的人。汤姆，你熟悉他吗？不熟悉。他是个绝对糟糕透顶的家伙。他就是现在还在政坛活跃的那个人吗？
Yeah. So he's the guy who wants to go in and murder everyone in Ukraine? He is. Yes, I am familiar with him. So he's an Instagram addict. He's had a tiff with John Oliver, the American comedy presenter on Instagram. He does have a comedy beard. His birthday party in 2011 was attended by jean-claude van damme
对。就是那个想要冲进乌克兰杀光所有人的家伙？没错。是的，我很熟悉他。他是个 Instagram（照片墙）网瘾患者。他在 Instagram 上和美国喜剧主持人约翰·奥利弗有过争执。他确实留着一抹滑稽的胡子。2011 年他的生日派对上来了尚格·云顿
uh hillary swank seal and vanessa may the violinist what a party that must have been well um i had a producer was telling us that john oliver is english but i think of him as american yeah he is english he was uh he was a comedy partner of andy zeltsin i know but he's famous the tms the test match special scorer He's not famous in England, is he? Well, that's two degrees of separation from Test Match Special to the Chechen warlord. Wow. Well, okay.
呃，希拉里·斯万克、海豹突击队（歌手 Seal）以及小提琴家瓦妮莎·梅。那场派对一定很盛大。好吧，呃，有个制作人刚才告诉我们约翰·奥利弗其实是个英国人，但我一直把他当成美国人。是的，他是英国人。他曾是安迪·泽尔茨的喜剧搭档。我懂，但他很有名，他是 TMS（《板球测试赛特辑》）的记分员。他在英国可不算有名，对吧？好吧，这中间隔了《板球测试赛特辑》和车臣军阀两层关系。哇。好吧，行吧。
That's brilliant. So anyway, you actually, the question was actually, I was just determined to read my notes about Ramzan Kevlar. No, fair enough. That was worth it. But the question was actually,
太精彩了。总之，其实，我刚才的问题是，我本来是一心想读我关于拉姆赞·卡夫拉（卡德罗夫）的笔记。好吧，没关系。那也挺值。不过问题其实是，
how did Putin win? Well, he won on the back of because he's fighting a communist isn't he ganadi zyuganov well yes right he's fighting zyuganov was the guy who he's um yeltsin beat in 96 and he's also going to run again in 2000 the communist uh putin is younger he's the new broom he's hard he's won the war so of course people vote for him he's very very good at um the weird thing is actually in 2000 if you look at some of the sort of press commentary in the west people said well maybe he'd be more liberal you know obviously we started the previous podcast with george w bush's now yeah frankly blackly ironic you know stuff about looking into his soul and inviting
普京是怎么赢的？好吧，他获胜是因为他在跟一个共产党人对决，对吧？根纳季·久加诺夫。哦，对的，没错。他的对手久加诺夫正是叶利钦在 96 年击败的那个人，而且他准备在 2000 年再次参选。共产党人嘛，呃，普京更年轻，他是新面孔，行事强硬，打赢了战争，所以人们自然投票给他。他非常非常擅长——奇怪的是，事实上在 2000 年，如果你看看西方的一些新闻评论，人们会说，也许他会更开明一些。你知道的，我们上一集播客以小布什那番——
him to his ranch because he thought he could trust him putin nobody actually knows what putin is putin is a blank slate um in in 2000 but he is lucky his reign coincides with a sort of uptick in in oil prices um and russia's going to start to make a lot of money from oil and gas. They've finally reached some degree of economic stability after the chaos of the 90s. Also, a thing that Putin does that isn't appreciated, I think, popularly in the West as much as it is, he cracks down on the oligarchs. He does, doesn't he?
说实话，现在看来极其讽刺的话开头，比如看进他的灵魂深处并邀请他去自己的农场，因为他觉得可以信任普京。其实没人真正了解普京。在 2000 年，普京是一张白纸。但他很幸运，他的统治恰逢石油价格回升的时期，俄罗斯开始从石油和天然气中赚取巨额资金。在经历了 90 年代的混乱之后，他们终于达到了某种程度的经济稳定。此外，普京还做了一件在西方没有得到应有赏识的事，那就是打击寡头。他确实这么做了，对吧？
Very popular. Yes, he does. So often people say now… Boris Berezovsky, the notorious one, isn't it? Well, it's notorious because he, of course, was found hanged in, I think, 2011. Outside Asgard. Yeah, there was this suspicion about what happened to him.
非常受欢迎。是的，他确实这么做了。所以现在人们经常说……鲍里斯·别列佐夫斯基，那个臭名昭著的人，对吧？嗯，他之所以臭名昭著，是因为他后来被发现上吊身亡，我记得是在 2011 年。阿斯克德（阿斯科特）郊外。是的，当时对他的死因有各种猜测。
And Khodorkovsky, also, who you mentioned earlier. Yes, exactly. The richest man in Russia. He was the richest man in Russia and had been very close to Yeltsin, had known Putin, there were lots of photos of them together, but had dared to criticise Putin and had to argue with him.
还有米哈伊尔·霍多尔科夫斯基，也就是你刚才提到的那个人。是的，没错。俄罗斯首富。他曾是俄罗斯首富，与叶利钦关系密切，也认识普京，有很多他们俩在一起的照片，但他却敢于批评普京，并与之争辩。
And basically Putin has him, you know, all of these oligarchs. Yeah, he's sent to prison for 10 years in Siberia. Very dastardly. Just absolutely. And then he serves his term and he gets another six years. Yeah, he's eventually, Putin pardoned him, I think, in 2014. Well, he's in London as well. Yeah. So all these, Putin pardoned him, I think, in 2014. And basically- He's in London as well.
基本上普京就把他——你知道的，把这些寡头都……是的，他被判处在西伯利亚服刑 10 年。非常卑鄙的手段。简直是。然后他刑满后又被加判了六年。对，普京后来在 2014 年特赦了他，我想是的。他在伦敦。对。所以所有这些——普京特赦了他，我想是在 2014 年。基本上——他也逃到了伦敦。
Yeah. I mean- So all these oligarchs flee to London. One of the things that people say about Abramovich is that, why did Abramovich buy Chelsea? Buying Chelsea was actually a brilliant way of protecting himself. It made him very famous, gave him a bolt hole in London, gave him a place in the kind of British and Western imagination. Oligarch- famous gave him a bolt hole in london gave him a place in the kind of british and western imagination oligarch as something other as something yeah as something other than just a
对。我是说——所以所有这些寡头都逃到了伦敦。关于阿布拉莫维奇，人们常说的一点是，为什么阿布拉莫维奇要买下切尔西？买下切尔西实际上是他保护自己的绝佳方式。这让他名声大噪，在伦敦为自己找了一个避难所，并在英国和西方公众的心目中占据了一席之地。作为一个寡头——成名让他在伦敦有了避难所，在英国和西方人的想象中为他赢得了一席之地，作为一个寡头而不是仅仅作为一个——
kind of the guy who ran sibneft and it made him harder to touch you know well because barakovsky takes him to court doesn't he in london barakovsky did take him they had a massive over the corpse of it they were absolutely so what's actually put Putin's reign in some ways has represented is the kind of securocrats, the siloviks, the siloviki, as they're called, taking power back. So people who are involved with the army, particularly with the intelligence services, they are the people who surround Putin now more than ever.
经营西伯利亚石油公司（Sibneft）的人，这让别人很难对付他，你知道的，因为别列佐夫斯基把告上了法庭，对吧，在伦敦。别列佐夫斯基确实把他告了，他们为了巨额财产闹得不可开交。所以，普京统治在某种程度上所代表的，其实是安全官僚，也就是所谓的西罗维基（Siloviki），重新夺回了权力。因此，那些与军队、特别是与情报机构有联系的人，如今比以往任何时候都更能环绕在普京周围。
Not so much the people with the sort of the glitzy yachts who made all their money in the 90s because there's been a bit of a backlash against them he's so it's the securocrats who really have taken have run the show in the last 20 years so to dominate one of i haven't read hugely about this period, but one book that really, really sticks in my mind was by Peter Pomerantsev, who was actually born in Kiev, I think. His parents were exiled to Britain, and so he grew up British. And then he went to Moscow to work in TV in the early years of Putin's presidency, and he wrote a brilliant book, Nothing is True and Everything is Possible. And his theme essentially is that Putin's power rests on his ability to manipulate reality, and that he is bringing the expertise that he has garnered as a KGB officer.
而不是那些在 90 年代靠着浮华游艇发财的人，因为社会对他们已经产生了一些强烈的反弹。所以，过去 20 年里真正掌权、主导一切的是安全官僚。那么，多米尼克，虽然我对这段时期没有深入阅读，但有一本书让我印象非常深刻，作者是彼得·波梅兰茨夫（Peter Pomerantsev），他好像出生于基辅。他的父母流亡到英国，所以他是在英国长大的。后来在普京总统任期的早期，他去了莫斯科的电视台工作，并写了一本精彩绝伦的书——《无物为真，一切皆可》（Nothing is True and Everything is Possible）。他的核心主题是，普京的权力建立在他操纵现实的能力之上，他正在运用自己作为克格勃军官所积累的专业知识。
And he is recruiting all the people, all this, all this kind of, the security services who've done this, quite a lot of the ideologues as well in the Soviet period. And they, you know, essentially he's weaponizing them. And Pomerantsev points out that when Putin becomes president, the first things that he essentially
他正在招募所有这些人员——所有这些安全部门里曾做过这些事的人，以及苏联时期的相当一部分意识形态专家。他们——你知道的，他基本上是在将他们武器化。波梅兰茨夫指出，当普京成为总统时，他首先将其爪子伸向的，
gets his claws on, it's not the utilities, it's not the utilities, it's not the oil, it's not even the security services, it's TV. And that he uses TV to create a kind of hall of mirrors. And I don't know whether you think that that's a theory that you would go along with. Well, you definitely see the hall of mirrors now, don't you? I mean, there are accounts, social media accounts online that are are i can't remember the name of the guy who's doing it there's a particular guy who's a francis something who's got this incredible account where he tells you what's on russian tv every night during the ukraine war and the
不是公用事业，不是石油，甚至不是安全部门，而是电视。他利用电视创造了一个镜厅（幻觉世界）。我不知道你是否认同这种理论。好吧，你现在确实能看到那个镜厅，对吧？我是说，网上有一些社交账户——我不记得那个人的名字了，有一个特定的人叫弗朗西斯什么的，他有一个不可思议的账号，每天晚上乌克兰战争期间都会播报俄罗斯电视上在放什么，以及
parallel world the parallel reality um you know the fact that basically they're showing pictures of kiev that are look like nothing that's happening now. They're fake, basically, or all these sort of things. I mean, you're right, there is a Hall of Mirrors, and to some extent there always has been. But I don't think it's purely that. I think for a lot of Russians, Putin does represent stability and strength
那个平行世界、平行现实——你知道的，基本上他们播放的基辅画面跟现实中发生的一切毫无关系。它们基本上是伪造的，或者诸如此类。我的意思是，你说得对，确实存在一个镜厅，而且在某种程度上一直都存在。但我认为不仅仅是这样。我认为对许多俄罗斯人来说，普京确实代表了稳定和力量，
because if you think about the story that we've told, the 80s and 90s, of course he represents stability after that utter chaos. And so that's the importance of his masculinity, the bare chest and all that kind of thing. Yeah, I think so. I mean, that's all laughable to us. than Boris not getting off the plane or Gorbachev, you know, just sort of lost in his own committees and reading Lenin
因为如果你想想我们讲述的故事——80 年代和 90 年代，在经历了那种彻底的混乱之后，他当然代表了稳定。所以这就是他的男子气概的重要性所在，光着膀子之类的事情。是的，我也这么觉得。我是说，对我们来说这都很可笑。相比于鲍里斯（叶利钦）下不了飞机，或者戈尔巴乔夫迷失在自己的委员会里、阅读列宁
and everything kind of falling to pieces around him. They see Putin projecting kind of old-fashioned masculine strength, don't they? And I think that obviously has a tremendous appeal. Plus there is this thing, you know, the Weimar parallel that you mentioned right at the beginning, there is this thing, the Weimar parallel that you mentioned right at the beginning,
以及周围一切分崩离析的样子，他们看到的是普京展现出的那种老式的阳刚之气，对吧？我认为这显然具有巨大的吸引力。再加上还有一件事——你在一开始提到的魏玛共和国的平行对照，你在一开始提到的
the Robert Harris thing. I mean, one of the things that animated Germany in the 1920s and then the 30s was the sense of amputation. There are all these Germans cut off. And Putin and his sort of ideologues, the people who are in this sort of TV hall of mirrors, they can say, well, you know,
罗伯特·哈里斯的观点。在 20 世纪 20 年代和 30 年代，激励德国的其中一种情绪就是“截肢感”（领土被割裂的失落感）。有那么多的德国人被隔绝在外。而普京和他的意识形态推销者们——那些身处电视镜厅里的人——他们可以说，
30% of the population of Estonia when the Soviet Union broke up was Russian speaking. All these people in Eastern Ukraine speak Russian. You know, people in Transnistria and Moldova. I mean, that's also what they've weaponized, a genuine sort of sense of grievance about what people see as the mutilation of kind of Russianness and the Russian nation. But also a sense that a war can be a kind of source of empowerment, that it will make Russians feel good while also, I guess, intimidating them.
苏联解体时，爱沙尼亚有 30% 的人口说俄语。乌克兰东部的这些人也说俄语。还有德涅斯特河沿岸和摩尔多瓦的人。我的意思是，这也是他们被武器化的一种情绪：对于人们眼中俄罗斯性和俄罗斯民族遭到残割的真切悲愤感。但同时这也是一种感觉，即战争可以成为一种赋权之源，它能让俄罗斯人在感到被威慑的同时，也对俄罗斯感到自豪。
Because, you know, you're getting this news footage from Grozny or whatever, and you're thinking, well, if he can do that there, what could he do to us? I mean, that's also, so there's a kind of, you're simultaneously being empowered and intimidated by this. Would that be true? I suppose that is true. People are frightened of, yeah, people are frightened of Putin. They'd be frightened of him even without a war. I mean, the war in Crimea, the annexation of Crimea,
因为，你知道的，你从格罗兹尼或其他地方看到这些新闻画面，你会想，如果他能在那里那样做，他会对我们做什么？我的意思是，这也是——所以其中有一种双重效应，你同时被这种力量所赋权，也被它所威慑。是这样吗？我想确实如此。人们对……是的，人们对普京感到恐惧。即使没有战争，他们也会怕他。我的意思是，克里米亚战争，吞并克里米亚——
and there wasn't really a war in Crimea, it was just a sort of a silent coup. The little green men and then the annexation. I mean, that was tremendously popular in Russia. Opinion polls showed it was very popular. The war in the Donbass, that's your hall of mirrors because Russians believe that they haven't been fighting in the Donbass. They think that it's purely separatists fighting Ukrainian Nazis. I mean, that stuff is crazy.
克里米亚其实并没有发生真正的战争，那只是一场无声的政变。小绿人出没，然后就是吞并。我的意思是，这在俄罗斯极其受欢迎。民意调查显示它非常受欢迎。至于顿巴斯战争，那就是你的镜厅了，因为俄罗斯人相信他们没有在顿巴斯参战。他们认为那纯粹是分裂分子在与乌克兰纳粹作战。我的意思是，这太疯狂了。
Okay, let's take a quick break, make a cup of tea, maybe have a slug of vodka, and we'll see you after the ads. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment
好吧，我们休息一下，去泡杯茶，也许喝一小口伏德卡，广告之后见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八卦，在我们的问答环节中，我们将拉开娱乐的帷幕，
and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to the rest is history so peter pomerantsev argues that in the noughties russian democracy you know it's it's all of it's it's it becomes show business it becomes a kind of source of entertainment that you allow people on political shows so you have communists you know to appeal
告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家加更节目以及提前购买现场门票的权限，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史的余烬》。彼得·波梅兰茨夫认为，在 20 世纪零年代，俄罗斯的民主——你知道的，这一切都变成了秀场，变成了一种娱乐源泉。你允许人们上政治节目，所以你有共产党人，你知道的，为了吸引
to the the old people and you have you know liberals to appeal to the the nerds and you have um nationalists you know who are kind of mad but but quite entertaining but it's like watching the big brother house and if you go too far you know if you start misbehaving if you start directly threatening putin then you'll be voted off the big brother house. You know, you will, you will just vanish. And so democracy is degraded into becoming a form of entertainment.
老年人；你有自由派，为了吸引书呆子；你还有民族主义者，你知道的，他们有点疯狂但相当具有娱乐性。但这就像在看《老大哥》（Big Brother）真人秀。如果你做得过头了——如果你开始不守规矩，如果你开始直接威胁普京，你就会被《老大哥》节目投票出局。你知道的，你会直接人间蒸发。因此，民主被贬低成了一种娱乐形式。
And then it just kind of fades away completely. Now I thought that was, you know, really, really kind of fascinating take, but the other thing, the other, I listened to a podcast.
然后它就彻底淡出了。现在我觉得这是一个非常、非常引人入胜的观点。不过还有一件事，我听了一个播客——
Tom, I actually listened to a podcast and it was jordan peterson's podcast well oh my god i can people are well people are either whooping for joy tom or they're oh they're turning off well now and he had on a guy called frederick kagan who's a military historian specialist in russia um son of uh famous classicist and he i would guess is pretty much the opposite of pomerantsev so peter pomerantsev writes for the lrb you know he's very much that that kind of world frederick kagan i would get well i mean definitely because he's on a jordan peterson podcast is not the kind of guy who would give his pronouns right but he definitely wouldn't give him to jordan peterson but he's basically he's basically saying the same thing he's talking about uh um putin's policy in
汤姆，我确实听了一个播客，那是乔丹·彼得森的播客。哦，天哪！人们要么在欢呼雀跃，汤姆，要么就在关掉节目。他采访了一个名叫弗雷德里克·卡根（Frederick Kagan）的人，他是一位军事历史学家、俄罗斯问题专家、著名古典学者的儿子。我想他基本上跟波梅兰茨夫完全相反。彼得·波梅兰茨夫为《伦敦书评》（LRB）撰稿，非常符合那种圈子。而弗雷德里克·卡根——我想，因为他上了乔丹·彼得森的播客，绝对不是那种会报出自己代词的人。他绝对不会把代词报给乔丹·彼得森的。但他基本上在表达同样的事情。他在谈论
crimea and he's he's talking about hybrid warfare this idea that you essentially what you're doing is you're creating again this idea of a hall of mirrors where nothing is real you can't be certain what anything is and his his aim is to get people particularly in the west but also in ukraine and russia to look at the war and to say well you know we don't really know what the truth is there's probably a bit of this is a bit of that when basically it's just an invasion and he he produced this astonishing fact i hadn't realized that the negotiations at minsk in 2014 to try and kind of arrive at a settlement between r and Ukraine. Russia isn't a kind of participant in the peace talks. It's an arbiter. It's there with France and Germany as an arbiter.
普京在克里米亚的政策，谈论混合战争——这种理念：你本质上在做的，是再次创造出一个“镜厅”概念，在这里一切都不是真实的，你无法确定任何东西的真假。他的目的是让人们——特别是在西方，但也包括在乌克兰和俄罗斯——看待这场战争时会说，“好吧，我们其实不知道真相是什么，这可能既有一点这个，又有一点那个。”而实际上它只是一场入侵。他给出了一个令人震惊的事实——我之前没意识到——2014 年在明斯克为达成俄乌解决方案而进行的谈判中，俄罗斯并不是和平谈判的参与者。它是仲裁者。它与法国和德国一同作为仲裁者出席。
Yeah, they're pretending that they're not. You see, that's the point. They're pretending they're not really involved. Yeah. Whereas what's changed this time around is that now Putin is doing absolutely nakedly. I mean, there's no attempt to create this kind of haul. I guess because it's been blown out of the water by the CIA. Well, but there is a haul of mirrors in Russia. I mean, there is a colossal chasm between what ordinary Russians think about the war and what we think about it that did not exist with, for example, when they went into Georgia in 2008. So that was probably the moment when that was the trial run, if you like, the war against Georgia.
是的，他们假装自己没有参与。你看，这就是重点。他们假装自己真的没有卷入。而这一次的不同之处在于，普京现在做得毫无遮掩。我的意思是，他根本没有试图制造这种大厅幻觉。我猜是因为 CIA 把这层伪装彻底戳穿了。嗯，但在俄罗斯国内确实存在一个镜厅。我的意思是，普通俄罗斯人对战争的看法与我们对战争的看法之间，存在着一条巨大的鸿沟。这在例如 2008 年他们进军格鲁吉亚时是没有的。那可能是试运行的时刻，如果你愿意的话，那就是针对格鲁吉亚的战争。
So George W. Bush, who appeared in the previous podcast, George W. Bush said, we're thinking about NATO membership for Ukraine and Georgia. They can aspire to it. And at that point, obviously, alarm bells went off in the Kremlin. And the first thing Putin did was go into Georgia just months later. So what happened then? Brutal war, all the rest of it.
所以小布什——曾在上一集中出现过的小布什——当时说，我们正在考虑让乌克兰和格鲁吉亚加入北约。他们可以对此抱有期望。就在那时，克里姆林宫显然拉响了警报。普京采取的第一个行动，就是几个月后直接出兵格鲁吉亚。那么当时发生了什么？残酷的战争，诸如此类。
But I don't think there was a sense then of an iron curtain, as it were. No, but even in 2014, there wasn't. Because there were lots of people in the West who said, oh, well know, Ukrainians are all fascists. That argument that Ukrainians are fascists, which was absolutely kind of generated by Putin's genius for malevolent propaganda. I mean, not entirely, but definitely quite significantly. And that played a crucial role in persuading the West not to get too het up about, you know. Yes, I suppose so.
但我认为当时还没有那种“铁幕”降临的感觉。没有，甚至在 2014 年也没有。因为西方有很多人说：“哦，好吧，你知道的，乌克兰人都是法西斯。”那种认为乌克兰人是法西斯的论调，正是由普京那恶毒宣传的天赋所催生出来的。我的意思是，虽然不完全是，但绝对起到了相当大的推动作用。这在说服西方不要对局势过度焦虑方面发挥了关键作用。是的，我想是的。
I mean, I think that, but also it's the fact that the Russians now are so sealed off. So, you know, it's virtually impossible now, I think, for ordinary Russians to get hold of a lot kind of hall of mirrors telling a story about what you're doing. How is that different from what people would have done in history? I mean, I'm thinking about- Well, it's funny you ask that because when I read Pomerantz's book, what it reminded me of was Augustine Rome. Yeah. The creation of fantastical stories that kind of almost anesthetized people
我的意思是，我认为，这也是因为俄罗斯人现在被完全隔绝了。所以，你知道的，现在普通俄罗斯人几乎不可能接触到——构建一个讲述你所作所为的故事的镜厅。这跟历史上的做法有什么不同？我在想——哦，很有趣你这么问，因为当我读波梅兰茨夫的书时，让我想起了奥古斯都时期的罗马。
who'd emerged from a civil war in a period of absolutely convulsive trauma and people embraced it and welcomed it that that you see do you know i'm so glad you mentioned that and it is funny how we because the parallel that's sometimes been in my mind with putin is you know i obviously think putin is a terrible person and wish him i mean i hope listeners won't be offended when I say I really do wish him all the worst. But he's on a spectrum and somewhere on that spectrum is Octavian, you know, who becomes Augustus, who obscure, people don't rate him, you know, does deals with the right people, can be utterly ruthless and cold well i think the difference is that um obviously octavian the the murderous terrorist who utilizes war to attain supreme power and then promote himself as a prince of peace the arc of putin is the other way that he's gone from presiding over bit taking
那些奇幻故事的创造，几乎麻痹了那些刚从内战中走出来、经历了一段极度痉挛创伤时期的人们，而人们接受并欢迎了它。你看，你知道吗？我太高兴你提到这一点了。有趣的是，我们如何看待——我有时脑海中与普京进行的平行对比是，你知道，我显然认为普京是个糟糕透顶的人，祝他——我是说，我希望听众不会因为我说我确实希望他倒霉而感到被冒犯。但他处于某种光谱上，而在这个光谱的某个地方是屋大维，也就是后来的奥古斯都——一个名不见经传、不被看好的人，与合适的人做交易，可以做到极其冷酷无情。嗯，我认为区别在于，显然屋大维这个利用战争来获取最高权力、然后把自己标榜为和平亲王的嗜血恐怖分子，而普京的发展轨迹正好相反，他从一个在西方——
in the west appearing to be a man with, Bush looks into his soul and it's good, who is now the new Hitler. Yeah, I suppose so. But surely, you think about Octavian and his war, for example, against Antony and Cleopatra, the way that Russian Augustan propaganda. Absolutely. No Roman would have got a sense of that war as we have of it
在西方看来似乎是一个好人——布什看进他的灵魂并觉得他不错——的人，现在变成了新希特勒。是的，我想是的。但是想想屋大维和他的战争，例如对安东尼和克利奥帕特拉的战争，俄罗斯奥古斯都式的宣传方式……绝对的。没有任何一个罗马人能像我们今天这样理解那场战争，
even our sense of the war is completely coloured by their propaganda so Putin's propaganda is not unprecedented in history absolutely not he truly is the third Rome that's a depressing thought I told you when we started I said I've got the flipping piles of notes. I know they've got the names of people running, you know, the under minister of tractors.
甚至我们对那场战争的理解也完全被他们的宣传所涂抹。所以普京的宣传在历史上并不是前所未有的，绝对不是。他真的是第三罗马，这是一个令人沮丧的想法。我一开始就告诉过你们，我说我有一大堆笔记。我知道上面有那些人的名字，比如负责拖拉机的副部长——
Yes, in minutes. That I haven't been able to use. But there are some brilliant books on this. There's a book by Serkii Plokhi, a Ukrainian historian called The Last Empire empire i think it is about ukraine and the the collapse of the soviet union there's the book i mentioned last time vladislav zubok's book and there are two other books tom that i'd like to mention because i think they are absolutely brilliant they're by the new yorker editor david remnick and he's talking about um uh russia in the late 80s and then in the early 90s now i can remember that the second one is called
是的，在会议上。那些我都用不上。不过关于这个主题有一些非常精彩的书。有一本书的作者是谢尔盖·普洛希（Serhii Plokhi），一位名叫乌克兰历史学家，书名叫《最后的帝国》（The Last Empire），我想是关于乌克兰和苏联解体的。还有我上次提到的弗拉季斯拉夫·祖博克的书。汤姆，还有另外两本书我想提一下，因为我认为它们真的精彩绝伦。作者是《纽约客》编辑大卫·雷姆尼克（David Remnick），他讲述了 80 年代末和 90 年代初的俄罗斯。我记得第二本书叫
resurrection and i can't actually remember the name of the first one having said how brilliant they are but i like to leave the list of something to do no it's not crucifixion i like to leave the list of something to do so then it is lenin's tomb yeah our producers just it that is an absolutely unbelievably good book um so i really recommend that um but yeah would you say it's a riddle wrapped in an enigma wrapped in a mystery or well i think that's going back to that kind of thing that we talked about the last podcast which is about the russian soul isn't it i think there were i'll tell you the in the rate what if tom i mean there's this is the great what if of our time what if the soviet union hadn't broken up would we be would a lot of people, there's an argument, I would, there's a reason, a lot of people who are anti-communists would say, God, what a terrible
《复活》（Resurrection），而我居然记不起第一本书的名字了，尽管我刚夸过它有多棒。不过我喜欢把这种悬念留给——不，不是《十字架上的基督》。我喜欢留点悬念，所以那是《列宁墓》（Lenin's Tomb）。是的，我们的制作人刚刚提醒了我，那真是一本好得令人难以置信的书。所以我极力推荐那本。但是，你会说这是一个谜中之谜、包裹在神秘之中的谜团吗？嗯，我想这又回到了我们上一集讨论的话题，关于俄罗斯灵魂，不是吗？我想，如果是这样的话——汤姆，如果发生这种情况会怎样？这是我们这个时代最伟大的“如果”之一：如果苏联没有解体，我们会怎样？很多人会争辩说——我有理由相信，许多反共人士会说：“天哪，多么可怕的设想！”但肯定也有人会认为，如果苏联继续存在下去，很多现在已经死去的人其实还会活着。
speculation. But there is surely an argument that a lot of people who are now dead would still be alive, actually, if the Soviet Union had kept going. If, let's say, Andropov had lived for another 10 years and then handed over to somebody more hard-nosed than Gorbachev, that it would still have been a bit repressive and autocratic, but it would have moved towards a market economy. Maybe still bad things would have happened, but perhaps not on the scale of the Chechen wars. But well, except what I'd say to that is that ever since the fall of the Soviet Union, the one thing that people across the world have been able to draw solace from is the fact that nuclear war between two rival superpowers is unlikely and perhaps the one of the well i think the most unsettling aspect of the current crisis is that um putin is now starting to talk about using nuclear weapons and one of the disturbed you know the reason that's disturbing is that people say oh
比方说，如果安德罗波夫再多活 10 年，然后把权力移交给一个比戈尔巴乔夫更务实、更强硬的人，那么它可能仍然会有点压抑和专制，但它会朝着市场经济方向发展。也许还是会有坏事发生，但至少不会达到车臣战争那种规模。不过，好吧，我要说的是，自从苏联解体以来，全世界人民能从中得到一丝慰藉的一点是：两个超级大国之间爆发核战争的可能性很低。也许其中最……我觉当前危机中最令人不安的方面，
it's just gamemanship but every threat threat he's delivered, every threat that he said he has actually acted on. Yes, there was a brilliant article by a woman called Fiona Hill. The British soft Russian expert in Washington, right? Exactly, the British expert who's recently been involved in all kinds of shenanigans in Washington. And she said, you know, every time people say he won't do this. He does it.
是普京现在开始谈论使用核武器了。令人不安的原因在于，人们说“这只是政治手腕”，但他发出的每一个威胁、说过的每一句话，他实际上都付诸行动了。是的，有一个名叫菲奥娜·希尔（Fiona Hill）的女性写过一篇精彩的文章。就是那个华盛顿的英国软实力俄罗斯专家，对吧？没错，就是那位最近卷入华盛顿各种政治勾当的英国专家。她说，每一次人们都说“他不会这么做的”，但他确实做了。
He does. Yeah. And in a way, that's the surprise about Putin, that he's turned out not to be this sort of coldly ruthless chess player, but he looks now
他确实这么做了。从某种意义上说，普京最令人意外的地方在于，他并没有成为那种冷酷无情的国际象棋大师，
more like a gambler whose gambles have succeeded and succeeded and succeeded. And now he's taken the biggest gamble of all. And as people often say, it'll either end with the destruction of Ukraine or the destruction of himself and his regime. And it's quite a dark story, you know, not just for Ukrainians, is it, but for Russians as well?
现在的他看起来更像是一个赌徒，他的赌局一次又一次地成功了。而现在，他押下了最大的一注。正如人们常说的那样，这一切要么以乌克兰的毁灭告终，要么以他本人及其政权的毁灭告终。这是一个相当黑暗的故事，不仅对乌克兰人来说是这样，对俄罗斯人来说也是如此，对吧？
Right, it is. Yeah, it is. It's a story of – it's funny, actually, because one of the things son had at Christmas, or I was given at Christmas, but he loves it, is the private eye annual for last year. He doesn't understand, he understands about 10% of 20% of the jokes. So we should explain that for people who aren't British, that it's a kind of satirical magazine that comes out fortnightly about British politics. and i think if you're in any way interested in politics and you're british it's it's a kind of gateway drug to understanding how politics it is exactly works because you have to work out who the characters are yeah so arthur loves it he likes all the jokes about boris and stuff um but he said to me he said gosh there are a lot of jokes here
没错，确实如此。这是一个关于——说起来很有趣，我儿子在圣诞节时收到的，或者说是我在圣诞节送他的礼物（但他自己非常喜欢），是上一期的《私人侦探》（Private Eye）年鉴杂志。他大概只能看懂 10% 到 20% 的笑话。所以我们应该为非英国听众解释一下，这是一本每两周出版一次、讽刺英国政治的杂志。如果你对政治感兴趣又是英国人，这简直是了解政治运作机制的“入门毒品”——
about vladimir putin and you wouldn't be able to do them today because, of course, he's Hitler now. And he was telling me how at school, you know, all the 10-year-olds say he's Hitler, all this stuff. They're all excited and discussing where they're going to hide in the event of a nuclear war and stuff in the way that 10-year-old boys do. And I sort of thought it is, you know, we did our very first podcast on the subject of greatness.
完全没错，因为你必须去猜这些角色都是谁。所以阿瑟很喜欢它，他喜欢所有关于鲍里斯（约翰逊）之类的笑话。但他对我说：“天哪，这里有好多关于弗拉季斯拉夫·普京的笑话，你现在肯定做不了这些了，因为他现在可是希特勒了。”他还告诉我，在学校里，所有的 10 岁男孩都说他是希特勒，诸如此类。他们都很兴奋，像 10 岁男孩那样讨论在核战争爆发时应该躲在哪里。我当时就在想，我们制作的第一期播客主题就是关于“伟大”。
And in that podcast, we ended by saying, is there anybody who will be regarded as great? And we talked about Vladimir Putin, certainly his sense of himself as great. And Russians, you know, he has, we talked about that sense of greatness that's born of martial prowess, glory, conquest, strength, the projection of the kind of image of virility that Alexander had and Pompey had and all these, I don't know, Henry VIII or Napoleon or whatever. And we talked about Putin. But of course, that's not a conversation we'd have in the same way today. Do you think, Tom?
在那个播客的结尾，我们提出了一个问题：有没有谁会被后世视作伟大的人物？我们谈到了弗拉季斯拉夫·普京，当然还有他对自己“伟大”的自我认知。俄罗斯人，你知道的，他拥有——我们谈到过那种源于军事武功、荣耀、征服、力量的“伟大感”，以及亚历山大和庞培所投射出的那种阳刚之气，无论是亨利八世还是拿破仑等等。我们当时聊到了普京。当然，我们今天不会以同样的方式来进行这种对话了，你觉得呢，汤姆？
No, we wouldn't um even though he's what he's doing to the cities in ukraine is what he'd already done in syria right in chechnya so and what conquer commanders have done in history in a way that people pass off in the footnotes oh by the way he leveled this city smashed up corinth he destroyed thebes he and we sort of say oh i know that was another sign of his of his greatness but actually when you read that against the news it makes you think a bit more deeply and we sort of say, oh, ha, ha, ha. I know that was another sign of his greatness. But actually, when you read that against the news, it makes you think a bit more deeply about the consequences. I think you're being harsh on us as a collective because I think we did push at those kind of paradoxes there
不，我们不会了。尽管他在乌克兰城市所做的事，其实就是他在叙利亚、车臣已经做过的事。这正是历代统帅们在历史上做过的事——而在脚注里人们常常轻描淡写地略过：“哦，顺便说一句，他夷平了这座城市，砸烂了科林斯，摧毁了底比斯。”我们当时会说：“哦，我知道，那是他伟大的又一个标志。”但实际上，当你把这些历史对照现实新闻来看时，会引发更深层次的思考。我们会说：“哦，哈哈，我知道那又是他伟大的一个标志。”但实际上，当你把这些历史对照当下的新闻来看时，会促使你更深刻地思考其带来的后果。我觉得你对我们的集体要求有点太苛刻了，因为我认为我们当时确实探讨了那种悖论，
and the moral complexities of the idea of greatness. When the war began, I put out a tweet where I said kind of Vladimir Putin, Peter the Great, or Anthony Eden. Oh, yeah, I saw that. Some people didn't like that. when the war began i put out a tweet where i said kind of vladimir putin peter the great or anthony eden oh yeah i saw that yeah and some people didn't like that some people were very very upset by that yeah i suppose i wasn't quite sure why they were upset i suppose the implication that that putin could in any way be great but obviously you know peter the great was great because he he built russia on the i mean you know in the case of st petersburg literally on the backs of the bones of those who built this
以及“伟大”这一概念背后的道德复杂性。战争刚爆发时，我发了一条推特，说的是：弗拉季斯拉夫·普京、彼得大帝还是安东尼·艾登？哦，对，我看到了。有些人不喜欢那个。战争刚爆发时，我发了一条推特，说的是：弗拉季斯拉夫·普京、彼得大帝还是安东尼·艾登？哦，对，我看到了。有些人对此非常非常反感。是的，我想我不太明白他们为什么反感。大概是因为暗示普京在任何方面都能称得上伟大。但显而易见，彼得大帝之所以伟大，是因为他把俄罗斯建立在——在圣彼得堡的例子中，字面意义上是建立在那些用北方泥滩建造这座非凡城市的建造者的累累白骨之上。尽管他杀了很多很多的人，但彼得大帝和斯大林一样，是普京心目中的两大英雄之一。那是他有意识地在追求的一种伟大模式。绝对如此。或者他最终会变成安东尼·艾登？也就是说，他会被制裁击垮吗？好吧，我觉得可以公平地说，我们是满怀希望的，对吧？但非同寻常的是，我仍然在努力去理解俄罗斯在过去几天里被隔绝在崭新铁幕之后的程度。你知道，现在没有任何媒体机构在俄罗斯运作，所以我们无法获得曾经拥有的相同信息。推特在俄罗斯被禁，所以——
extraordinary city out of the kind of the mud flats of uh of the north but i mean he killed a lot of people and peter the great like stalin is one of the two great heroes of of put. And that is a kind of model of greatness that he's consciously aspiring to. Absolutely. Or will he turn out to be Antony Eden, i.e. will he be brought down by sanctions? Well, I mean, I think it's fair to say that we're hopeful, aren't we? But the extraordinary thing is that I'm still kind of struggling to get a sense of is the extent to which russia in the last few days has been cut off behind a renewed iron curtain you know none of these media organizations now working in russia so we're not getting the same information we were once getting twitter banned in russia so you know
我们无法获得同等流量的社交媒体信息。这种可能性意味着，在接下来的几个月里，俄罗斯城市将发生一些事情，而我们只能像 80 年代那样，从支离破碎的报道中获取信息，却根本不知道到底发生了什么。人们在发餐厅评论，对吧？是的，是的，我有看到。利用谷歌地图评论试图将信息传递给俄罗斯人。
we're not getting the same flow of social media um and this possibility that actually in the next you know few months things will happen will happen in cities in russia and we'll just take garbled reports of them as we would have once done in the 1980s months, things will happen in cities in Russia and we'll just take garbled reports of them as we would have once done in the 1980s and actually not know what's happening. People are posting restaurant reviews, aren't they? Yes, yes, I have. Google Maps reviews to try and get messages across to Russians.
反之亦然。他们是不是也在评价斯通沃尔（Stonewall）的茶室？是的。“救命，我们遭到袭击了”之类的内容。天哪，是的。我敢肯定，如果我们在播客里谈论这个，俄罗斯安全部门肯定也盯上这事了。他们会听这个播客吗？我怀疑，我非常怀疑。不管怎样，这一切都令人沮丧。但我们在那四集里讲述的故事——我现在真希望能更深入地探讨这个话题。
But also vice versa. Are they posting reviews of tea rooms in Stonewall? Yes. Help, we're being attacked kind of thing all right golly yeah yeah i'm sure that'll be clear i mean if we're talking about it on a podcast i'm sure the uh the russian security services are on to that jeff and they listen to this podcast i doubt it i very much doubt it anyway uh all very depressing um but the story that we told in those four episodes so i now i now wish you know i want
我甚至有点希望我们能挖掘得更深，尤其是 90 年代的俄罗斯，那是一个如此疯狂的时期。至少那绝对是“狂野东方”，有太多的故事——多米尼克·卡明斯（Dominic Cummings），鲍里斯·约翰逊昔日的顾问、如今最激进的批评者、英国脱欧的大脑，他在 90 年代曾在俄罗斯待过，当时好像试图开发一家航空公司，对吧？他当时大约 10 岁吧？
to do that subject for ages and i and i slightly wish we'd done it in even more depth um because particularly i think russia in the 90s it was such a crazy period and at least what it was absolutely the wild east there's so many i mean domin Dominic Cummings, Boris Johnson's erstwhile advisor, now fiercest critic, sort of the brains of Brexit. He was in Russia in the 1990s, I think trying to develop an airline. Isn't that right? And he was about 10, wasn't he? Yeah.
我想他刚大学毕业就直接去了俄罗斯，就像当时某些人做的那样。当然，有些人因此变得极其富有。但那种掠夺、寡头政治与生活水平的急剧下降、贫困，以及疯狂的政治结合在一起……我们没有充分触及的另一个事实是——虽然我们把它比作魏玛共和国，
I think he just left university and went straight to Russia in that way that some people did. And some people obviously became incredibly rich. But the combination of that, of the looting and the oligarchs, with the collapse in living standards, the poverty, but also the insane politics. So another thing we didn't massively touch on was the fact that, I mean, we talked about it as Weimar,
但俄罗斯当时的政治局势实在是极端至极。例如，当时存在着如此严重的反犹太主义和狂热的民族主义。一个真正非同寻常的现象是，在 90 年代，所有这些不同的政治力量居然凝聚在了一起——你可以称之为一种“红褐联盟”（共产主义与法西斯的结合体）……我已经用了两次“凝聚”这个词了，不过没关系。
but the political scene in Russia was so extreme. And there was so much anti-Semitism, for example, and fervent kind of nationalism. And one of the really remarkable things is that right is that in the 90s all these different political forces kind of coalesced behind this what you would call you could call a kind of red brown you know communist stroke fascist um coalescence as the I've used coalesce twice but there you Um, so I was only just seeing yesterday, the head of the communist party who we mentioned in the podcast, Gennady Zyuganov.
所以，我昨天才刚看到，我们在播客中提到过的共产党领导人根纳季·久加诺夫，
He came second to Yeltsin in 96. He gave a press conference yesterday, Tom, yesterday saying that, um, NATO and the Americans have established biological weapons labs in Georgia, Kazakhstan, and Ukraine just over the border.
他在 96 年的大选中输给叶利钦获得第二名。他昨天开了一场新闻发布会，汤姆，就在昨天，他说北约和美国已经在格鲁吉亚、哈萨克斯坦和乌克兰边境附近建立了生物武器实验室。
And they're preparing their biological and chemical weapons to attack the Russian people. And that's why, you know, Putin should go further and go faster kind of thing. I thought, how at least he hasn't said put them in the Baltic Republics, which would be no, I suppose that would be terrifying. So Dominic, I mean, I'm aware that we're now getting strung into politics and we're we don't want to do a Rory alistair campbell do we don't we don't but just just because you know much more about this than me the the end game i mean what is there any conceivable end game it's really that you can see because i mean it's obviously gone terribly wrong for putin the war's gone wrong gone badly yeah the economy has been hit much worse than he'd anticipated
他们正在准备生物和化学武器来攻击俄罗斯人民。这就是为什么普京应该走得更远、动作更快。我想，至少他还没说把实验室建在波罗的海共和国，那可就太——不，我想那会更吓人。所以，多米尼克，我的意思是，我意识到我们现在又扯进政治里了，我们可不想变成罗里和阿拉斯泰尔·坎贝尔（Rory and Alastair Campbell）那样，对吧？我们不想这样。不过，鉴于你比我更了解这些，最后的结局——我的意思是，你觉得能看到任何可能的结局吗？因为这显然对普京来说糟透了，战争进展不顺，一塌糊涂，是的。经济受到的打击比他预期的要严重得多。
there's no the only way that he can really row back is to kind of say i got it wrong and he's never going to do that he's not going to do that no so the only option really seems to be to escalate it isn't it and to to try and get in a kind of fight fight with nato i mean that's a very very grim um way of putting it i think he so my reading of it is this that putin like so many people ended up believing his own propaganda just being surrounded by people who told him what he wanted to hear that the west was weak the ukraine was basically a complete shambles and a frankenstein's monster of a country do you think he really thought that they were a bunch of nazis i mean he's literally saying about a state led by a jewish president i mean that's crazy i think there's a bit of him
他唯一能退缩的办法就是承认自己错了，但他绝不会这么做，他绝对不会，对吧？所以唯一的选择似乎只能是升级局势，不是吗？试图与北约发生某种冲突，我是说，这是一种非常非常严峻的表述方式。我认为普京——我的理解是这样的——像许多人一样，最终相信了自己的宣传，周围都是顺从他的人，告诉他他想听的话：西方很弱，乌克兰基本上是一团糟，是个拼凑出来的弗兰肯斯坦怪物。你觉得他真的认为他们是一群纳粹分子吗？我是说，他竟然在说一个由犹太总统领导的国家，这太疯狂了。我觉得他心里有一部分
it's impossible to say isn't it did did hit there's a bit of him. It's impossible to say, isn't it? Did Hitler believe all the mad things that Hitler... Yes, I think he did, didn't he? I suppose he did. Did Stalin? Yes. You end up believing it yourself, don't you? I mean, this is the thing with politicians.
这很难说，不是吗？希特勒是否……他心里有一部分——这很难说，不是吗？希特勒相信了所有那些疯狂的事情……是的，我想他是信的，对吧？我想是的。斯大林呢？是的。你最后自己也信了，不是吗？我是说，政客就是这样。
You end up... Part of you knows that some of it is contrived, exaggerated, all of that stuff, but you end up convincing yourself, especially if you're in an echo chamber where other people just articulate your prejudices to you. Or is it an illustration of my thesis that Hitler has become the devil and that your enemies, if you're in a kind of Manichaean, good and evil, light and dark, your enemies have to be Nazis because that's the only
你最终……你心底的一部分知道有些东西是人为捏造的、夸大其词的，诸如此类，但你最终还是说服了自己，尤其是当你身处一个回音室里，周围的人只是在不断迎合和表达你的偏见时。或者这恰好说明了我的论点：希特勒已经成了恶魔，如果你处于一种二元对立的视角中——善与恶、光明与黑暗——你的敌人就必须是纳粹，因为那是唯一的
possible justification. That's absolutely true in Russia because what's happened in russia in the last 20 years is the second world war i mean god think how much we beat ourselves up in britain about this uh the second world war has become a stifling kind of national myth so everything is seen through that prism um and and in a way yeah they're now even if there's no evidence of nazism whatsoever i mean by the way there are there are far-right extremists in Ukraine, but they are such a minority on the political spectrum. They don't even hold, I think, any seats in the Ukrainian parliament. No, and to repeat, their president is Jewish.
合理的正当理由。在俄罗斯，这绝对是真的，因为过去20年里俄罗斯发生的事情就是第二次世界大战。天哪，想想我们在英国是如何为此反思的吧。第二次世界大战已经变成了一种令人窒息的民族神话，所以一切都透过这个滤镜来看待。从某种程度上说，是的，即便没有任何纳粹主义的证据——顺便说一句，乌克兰确实有极右翼极端分子，但他们在政治光谱中只占极少数，甚至在乌克兰议会中没有任何席位。是的，而且再次重申，他们的总统是犹太人。
Their president is a Russian speaker and is Jewish. Exactly, Tom. And so part of the paradoxical horror of what's happening is that the Russians have become their worst nightmares. They're making Stalingrads out of Ukrainian cities in which they are playing the part of the Germans. They are indeed. And they're laying siege to Kiev as the Mongols laid siege to it. So they're playing the part of the Mongols. Yeah, agreed. I mean, it's a terrible situation. Anyway, you asked about the endgame lay siege to it. So they're playing the part of the Mongols. Yeah, agreed.
他们的总统是俄语使用者，而且是犹太人。完全正确，汤姆。因此，正在发生的事情所带来的荒诞恐怖之处在于，俄罗斯人已经成了他们自己最大的噩梦。他们把乌克兰的城市变成了斯大林格勒，而他们在其中扮演的角色正是德国人。他们的确如此。他们像当年的蒙古人一样对基辅进行围城。所以他们在扮演蒙古人的角色。是的，完全同意。我的意思是，这真是个糟糕的局势。不管怎样，你刚才问到结局是什么……他们像蒙古人一样对基辅进行围城。所以他们在扮演蒙古人的角色。是的，完全同意。
I mean, it's a terrible situation. Anyway, you asked about the endgame. Sorry, Tom, I rambled and didn't answer. You asked about the endgame. Pugin is now in a position where when he wakes up in the morning and thinks about his options, continuing fighting is probably his least worst option as he sees it. He can't stop and say it was all a mistake.
我的意思是，这真是个糟糕的局势。不管怎样，你刚才问到结局是什么。抱歉，汤姆，我刚才扯远了，没有回答你的问题。你问的是结局。普京现在处於这样一种境地：当他早晨醒来考虑自己的选择时，继续战斗可能是他眼中损失最小的选择。他无法停下来承认这一切都是个错误。
He can't really declare victory and go home i don't think um there's almost no way back for him now with the west it's hard to see you know it's not like he can say he can say sorry i've made a mistake and people will relax the sanctions i mean that's not really how it works i think he thinks i will just power through he perhaps thinks there'll be if there's a change of administration in America, if the West will lose interest, people get bored, I'll present them with a fait accompli. I mean, he's no stranger to frozen conflicts as well.
我不认为他真的能宣布胜利然后回家。现在他跟西方之间几乎已经没有退路了，很难想象……这不像是他说一句“对不起，我犯了个错误”，然后大家就会取消制裁。事情显然不是这样的。我想他心里想的是：我只要硬扛过去就行了。他或许认为，如果美国政府发生更迭，或者西方失去耐心、人们感到厌烦，他就可以造成既成事实。而且，他对冷冻冲突也并不陌生。
So Georgia, Transnistria, places like that, where basically the Russians are still there, but there's just a stalemate in these places. So perhaps he thinks I'll just keep fighting. It'll end up being a stalemate in Ukraine forever and ever. And eventually I'll get what I want because they'll lose interest and all this stuff. I mean, the problem he'll have is losses of troops and losses of money. Expensive losses of money. Yeah, you're right. I mean, the trouble is a lot of young Russians have been connected, haven't they, to the sort of world network.
比如格鲁吉亚、德涅斯特河沿岸那些地方，俄罗斯人实际上还在那里，但这些地方陷入了僵局。所以他可能觉得，我会继续打下去。乌克兰最终会变成一个无休止的僵局。最终我会得到我想要的东西，因为他们会失去耐心，诸如此类。我的问题是，他将面临军队和金钱的巨大损失。代价高昂的金钱损失。是的，你说得对。问题是，许多年轻的俄罗斯人已经与这种世界网络连接在一起了，不是吗？
I mean, just even small things like they're not going to get Netflix, they're not going to get the new cinema releases, they're not going to get Apple products, they're not going to get all these things. And of course, these are all kind of middle class things. But often the middle class is the very people who drive revolutions and regime changes. Sorry, this is a very morbid end to the podcast, Tom.
我是说，哪怕是一些小事，比如他们将无法观看Netflix，无法观看新的电影上映，无法购买苹果产品，无法获得所有这些东西。当然，这些都是中产阶级的生活方式。但通常正是中产阶级在推动革命和政权更迭。抱歉，以这样一个非常阴郁的话题来结束这期播客，汤姆。
Well, it's a morbid subject, isn't it? It's hard not to feel depressed about it. We should be back, hopefully, with more jolly material. Maybe Tom will do some impersonations next time to cheer us up. And on that note, we'll say thank you for listening. Goodbye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History.
好吧，这本来就是一个阴郁的主题，不是吗？很难不对其感到沮丧。我们希望下期会带来更多轻松愉快的内容。也许汤姆下次会模仿几个人来让我们高兴起来。就此而言，我们要感谢大家的收听。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。
For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip.
想要收听独家加更节目、提前解锁内容、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请前往 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、精彩评论以及各种八卦八卦。
And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在我们的问答环节中，我们将为娱乐产业揭开神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想享受无广告收听、加更节目并提前购买现场演出门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。